how's it going everybody it's Warren
Merry Christmas Eve to everybody that is
celebrating and Happy Hanukkah to those
who are celebrating Hanukkah as well
it's been a while but we have some
awesome venom to news today including a
plot leak and a confirmation of a new
character now what's interesting about
this character is that this character
can be a villain but this character
could also be an antihero as well and
what's even more interesting about this
character is his story it's a story that
involves venom carnage and spider-man
and a story that even brings venom and
carnage together makes them team up to
fight against this person although I
shouldn't say person I should say
symbiote that's right there's
confirmation that a new symbiote is
coming to venom 2 so let's jump into
this let's talk about this new character
and talk about this new plot leaked that
of course involves venom carnage and
what everybody's hoping for it's
spider-man don't forget to subscribe
with notifications turned on like the
video and comment so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 also only 7 days left and the
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway so be sure to
click the link in the description down
below so I have to put out a spoiler
warning for this leak because the person
who posted this on reddit says they have
confirmed that this leak is true from an
official source apparently this source
was subcontracted out by Sony but of
course you never really know with leaks
so take it with a grain of salt but
let's start with the new character and
start with an official photo from venom
2 as you can see right here this photo
from venom 2 says detective Mulligan now
for those of you who do not know that is
Patrick Mulligan and Patrick is famous
for being the host of the symbiote toxin
so it seems like this is an official
confirmation that toxin is going to be
in venom 2 now like I mentioned before
toxin is not really a hero not really a
villain he's kind of been both but for
the most part he's really an antihero
but toxins story is really quite
interesting especially the way that it
involves venom carnage and spider-man
and the story actually ties into the
plot leaked really well so just like
carnage is supposed to be the offspring
of venom toxin is supposed to be the
offspring of carnage now we aren't
actually sure about the way that venom 2
is going to take things yet and venom to
the symbiotes all came from
another planet which of course is
accurate but there's been no talk about
any of them producing offsprings so it's
unclear on whether or not venom is
actually going to have an offspring and
that offspring will be carnage and then
carnage will have an offspring that is
toxin or if the symbiotes are simply
going to come to earth from their planet
as well so it's unclear on how Sony is
actually going to depict them in venom
two but for the sake of the story we're
going to say that carnage is the
offspring of venom and toxin is the
offspring of carnage so Patrick Mulligan
first appeared in the comics in venom
carnage number one in 2004 and toxin
first appeared in venom carnage number
two in 2004 as well and just like I said
just like venom had carnage carnage had
toxin now carnage hated toxin even
before he was born he hated him from the
start fearing that he could become even
stronger than himself and he was just
disgusted at the thought of giving birth
which was a reflection of the attitude
of carnage as host Cletus Kasady
during this time venom the father of
carnage and soon-to-be grand father of
toxin found out that carnage was about
to have toxin and he sought him out to
talk about the new symbiote carnage his
plan was to immediately kill the new
symbiote as soon as it was born
however venom had different plans for
the symbiote he wanted to keep him alive
because he wanted a new partner
since carnage wasn't exactly the best
son but venom was also worried because
this symbiote was going to be the 1000th
symbiote in their line and venom was
worried that this new symbiote could
potentially become violent and psychotic
because of a genetic breakdown when
carnage eventually had the symbiote he
felt like he was too weak to destroy it
so he planted it into Patrick Mulligan
and he left but he had every intention
on coming back and killing the symbiote
when carnage felt much stronger now
Patrick Mulligan was actually a very
stand-up guy he was one of New York
City's finest cops he just happened to
be at the wrong place and the wrong time
when he came across carnage giving birth
to toxin as I said before carnage bound
the symbiote to Patrick Mulligan with
the intentions on coming back and
killing him later
however venom still wanted toxin as a
partner so carnage and venom go at it
they fight until eventually they come to
a standstill now like I said Patrick
Mulligan was a good guy he had a wife
Gina who was pregnant with their son
Edward carnage would eventually end up
attacking Gina and
and Patrick realized that the symbiote
was a threat to him and his family
during another confrontation with toxin
and carnage and venom venom realized
that Patrick Mulligan was dedicated to a
life of virtue and that he could
actually use the symbiote toxin for good
and it was becoming very apparent that
the symbiote toxin was becoming even
stronger or just as strong as venom and
carnage
so venom and carnage make a temporary
pact to kill toxin during the final
confrontation between toxin venom and
carnage venom and carnage probably would
have defeated and killed toxin if it
wasn't for the intervention of our
friendly neighborhood spider-man Peter
Parker aka spider-man stumbles across
venom and carnage trying to kill toxin
and he helps toxin get away toxin has a
talk with spider-man and he tells him
everything that happened everything with
carnage attacking his family and with
venom as well
spider-man encourages Patrick Mulligan
and toxin to resign himself to a life of
battling his base symbiote urges while
trying to harness his power for good
Patrick
agrees with him so he leaves his wife he
leaves his child and he leaves the
police force and starts a new life as
toxin now as you can see here from the
origin story of toxin he actually ties
together venom and carnage in a really
good way
at first venom and carnage fight against
each other then they fight together and
then they fight against toxin and
spider-man but again we don't know if
Sony in venom 2 is going to go the route
of where carnage is Venom's offspring
and toxin is Carnage's offspring so we
don't really know the nature of how
toxin is going to be he could be a bad
symbiote that works with carnage or he
could be a good one who works with venom
we don't really know but thanks to a
plot leak we have an idea of not just
how toxin but other symbiotes as well
are going to come into play in venom 2
and possibly make giant carnage now
according to this plot leaked carnage is
the spawn of venom and that's how Cletus
gets the symbiote riot isn't dead and
when carnage gets set loose that is when
screech will come into the picture in
the first film Eddie asked venom after
he eats somebody asking if he's going to
eat any more people and venom says that
is why we are here we find out that
riots mission is to alert the symbiotes
on their home planet that there are
quality hosts on earth to feed on the
problem is that Cletus is insane
nnedi corrupts the carnage symbiote and
the symbiote becomes cannibalistic to
its own kind in the first venom when
riot absorbs venom at the end of the
movie that is what we will see when all
the symbiotes reached Earth except
carnage will absorb all of them forming
the giant carnage from the comics
carnage screech and riot will team up
against venom who will once again be
trying to stop the symbiotes from
cummings earth the whole movie because
he now feels sympathy and empathy for
the other human beings which will
inevitably fail venom will not be able
to stop carnage and the rest of them he
already had a hard enough time fighting
riot in the first venom movie but as the
leak previously mentioned carnage has
become cannibalistic carnage will
pretend to be partners with screech and
riot only to eat them at the end when
the time is right this is where
spider-man comes in and this is where a
spider-man team-up will occur to defeat
giant carnage spider-man and venom
eventually do defeat giant carnage and
at the end
venom is about to kill Cletus Kasady but
spider-man stops him the two of them
have a confrontation and then venom
turns on spider-man and this is how the
spider-man venom cinematic feud will
start promoting a spider-man venom movie
afterwards if this plot league ends up
being true this is something that fans
have been waiting for for a very long
time a spider-man vs. venom film because
although we are probably going to get a
cameo from spider-man in venom 2 it's
really going to be about venom and
carnage but according to this plot leak
spider-man is going to show up at the
end to help venom save the day which
makes a lot of sense because in the
first venom movie venom had a hard
enough time defeating riot and carnage
is the worst of the worst and he's going
to have some help in this movie shriek
has basically already been confirmed to
be in venom - and if riot isn't dead and
some other symbiote show up as well
there's no way venom is walking out of
this alive and that is where spider-man
comes into play and possibly toxin now
since they are according to this league
going with the whole carnage is the
spawn of venom things and they could
probably go with toxin as the spawn of
carnage and they could really go either
way they can make it to where carnage
hates toxin and then toxin fights with
venom and spider-man or they can make it
to where carnage actually Tricks toxin
and then at the end he absorbs him as
well but either way it's looking like
venom definitely has his hands full and
he's definitely going to need some help
from a friendly neighborhood spider-man
and
this point in time we've heard enough
plot leaks all of which say that
spider-man is going to show up in venom
two now of course nothing is official
unless the studio confirms it but we do
know that Sony actually filmed a scene
for the first venom movie that had Tom
Holland in it
we know that Sony has been wanting Tom
Holland to be in their universe for some
time now but Marvel said no because they
didn't want people to be confused they
didn't want people to think that venom
was a part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe when he's not so having Tom
Hollands spider-man appear in a venom
film could be quite confusing since
spider-man is in the MCU but now as
everybody I'm sure knows Sony and Disney
just worked out a new deal for
spider-man and a lot of people think and
speculate that that new deal for
spider-man to remain in the MCU could
have included a spider-man gets to
appear in a venom film and possibly even
set up a spider-man vs. venom movie but
we have to deal with venom two first
which sounds like it's going to be an
amazing movie just off of everything
that we've heard so far right now we
know that venom 2 is going to be venom
carnage shriek and now toxin and
hopefully all these plot leaks end up
being true and we get to see a cameo
from spider-man as well so let me know
what you think about this news of toxin
being in venom
2 also let me know what you think about
the possibility of giant carnage
entering venom 2 as well be sure to
comment down below with your thoughts
like the video and don't forget to
subscribe when notifications turned on
to stay up to date with everything and
so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
don't forget only 7 days left for the
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway so click the
link in the description down below
use code cosmic at G feel calm for 30%
off g feel and as always thank you all
so much for watching well for